hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
I'm going be talking about you know
picking the right chart for you okay
because this is a question I get a lot
you know Mike what's uh the best chart
for me to look at this Market uh using a
footprint chart and by this Market I
mean you know whether it's uh snps or
NASDAQ or eurocurrency or bonds um I'm
going to discuss that
and before I jump in if you haven't
already be sure to subscribe to the
channel and click that notification Bell
so you don't miss any new uploads right
and if you find this video helpful be
sure to hit that like button for me and
leave a comment sharing your biggest
takeaway because you know I love hearing
your feedback and oftentimes it's from
your feedback that I get ideas uh for
new videos and and this video sort of
comes from that feedback and let's go
ahead and get started with today's topic
all right choosing the right chart or
you know some people say the perfect
chart well there is no perfect chart for
every Trader there is a perfect chart
for you though right and really what it
comes down to is looking at the market
in a
way that's going to allow you to make
sense of the order flow okay so for
example um you know snps is a market
that trades pretty normally okay now if
it was a market like say Ultra bonds
okay this is ultra Bonds on a four range
chart it helps me understand what I'm
looking at okay if I was looking at a
time based chart in a market like Ultra
bonds right it's going to be it's
possible but there's going to be times
where it's just like this here where
it's just basically trading the bid and
the offer one tick above maybe one tick
below you know where it's just basically
one price level here here you know here
here here and it's going to be difficult
that's why I prefer on markets like
interest rates to use a four range chart
because now I'm seeing the market
move based on price movements or in the
sense rather bars printing based off of
price movements um snps e- minis rather
trade nicely you get enough volatility
in the bars to be able to um make sense
of the order flow you're looking at as
opposed to sort of a flatline now the
next step is depending on what exactly
you're looking at in the order
flow does in my opinion have some
relevance to um
taking advantage of the order flow right
you want to take advantage of order flow
as early as possible right if it's
bullish order flow or bearish order flow
okay because again there is in my
opinion sort of a sell by date right
imagine right you're looking at order
flow and you see something bearish right
you see like for example stack selling a
balance you want to take advantage of
that as soon as
possible because the longer you
you know waiting for the bar to form or
something it may not be noticeable and
you may have missed your opportunity so
for example right if let's just really
quickly here go to a f minute e mini
chart okay and you'll notice today yeah
there were there was you know some
stacked imbalances right
here if what you're looking for is
stacked imbalances yeah you have one
that came in here at 504 and
A4 right you don't see any stacked
imbalances here and here and why not
well it's because the market had plenty
of time to sort of come in and fill that
in okay so I mean look at this here so
from basically going back to the cash
open right this is 830 here you see only
one stack imbalance and it's this one
stack buying balance right here right
there's nothing
else now if I were to go on a shorter
time frame say 30 seconds again this is
dependent on what you want to analyze in
the order flow whether it's stacked IM
balances or anything else okay so here
on a 30 second chart I got a nice trade
here nice stack selling IM balance
here right basically from you know 5010
down to
04 you know there was another stack
buying of balance here this is that one
that was at 04 you know you had one here
coming in around 99 right before we took
out that
High um yeah nice little stack selling a
balance here for a little move down nice
buying imbalance here for a move up okay
so you're seeing if if that's what
you're focusing on stack
imbalances what is usually what causes a
stacked imbalance well usually what
causes a stacked imbalance is a big
order going through the market really
quick okay because you know someone's
like oh you know hey like you know over
here hey buy
me 700 E minis at the market okay people
say well who would buy 700 at the market
but doesn't matter it's coming through
really quick right the big Traders they
will buy stuff at the market um you know
usually if the Market's Trad 99 and a
half they'll say just pay pay if it's
trading 90 and a half rather say payt 91
and a half or you know 700 their average
price is probably going to be somewhere
around
91.26 or something which they're happy
about because they know their order is
going to have an influence on the market
okay so that's why you know if you're
looking at stacked
imbalances you want to be able to take
advantage of them as soon as they happen
the sooner the better now people are
going to say well why don't you go on
like a shorter chart I don't know um I
don't want to go down to a 5c chart but
you know a 15-second chart well you
could in theory um by I think for most
Traders that's too fast a lot of Traders
will will probably Panic or start to
pull the the trigger too much um you
know you still got that imbalance here
you got an imbalance here you got an
imbalance here um you know sort of
coming back to where we are now um You
got a little buying imbalance here one
here so there's sort of a tradeoff right
because you don't want to have too many
signals you still want to give the
market time to react rather than just a
big order hitting the market right if
you have a big order hitting the market
okay let's just go back here to a 302
chart you have a big order hitting the
market that's causing an imbalance in
the market all right so for example here
or
here what you want to see is some sort
of follow
through okay because one thing is to
have a big order hit the
market great it gives you a sign that
hey you know what there's an aggressive
Trader here but if there's no other
aggressive Traders coming in like like
here afterwards like for the next this
is a 30 second chart for the next 1
minute minute and a half two minutes
Market's not going down really what you
want to see is the big order come in the
big aggressive Trader come in then you
want to see some form of more aggression
coming in okay and you start to see it
obviously what's the first sign do you
need more imbalances yeah that's nice
but you want to see price go
lower right over the next couple of bars
yeah technically did go down here you
well Market went down by one tick and it
didn't Well yeah if it's just holding in
there right if it's coming back to where
that aggressive selling was and it's
just holding chances are it's not going
to do well obviously another
um sign that I'm always looking for is
what's happening you know are we going
inside or what right like here this one
went inside this one went inside this
one just barely missed it but you know
really what you want to see is some sort
of follow follow through in the market
okay so again if you were to look at an
eight range
chart I minis you know I used I used to
use eight range charts a lot people say
why why don't I use it now because again
I've sort of changed my outlook of the
market as we're trading at higher prices
it's a nice stack sell a balance okay
next bar obviously lower again here's a
nice stack selling balance next bar one
tick lower then you pull right back up
into that imbalance right the in my
opinion the best imbalances don't get
traded back into
immediately and if you're looking for
some sort of confirmation right if it
does pull back it should hold here it
holds here it holds here it holds it
doesn't trade back into here it doesn't
hold gets on the other side of it pretty
quick okay so again looking at charts
trading is a a journey right it's a
personal Journey
actually and finding the right chart
type takes time right I see people you
know trading NASDAQ right they they use
a 20 range chart okay fine that that
works for them me if I look at NASDAQ M
andq right I got a 15sec chart here
okay because I know I could see what's
happening now the problem you know I
don't honestly I don't spend a lot of
trading NASDAQ I do look at it
occasionally um just moves a little bit
too fast for me I I prefer markets that
aren't jumping around and but the
problem is a lot of Traders right they
see people post stuff on chat groups and
things like that on Facebook in I say
Instagram but Facebook and oh yeah I
caught this big run in the NASDAQ
well they're a different type of Trader
than maybe you
are so you got to understand the type of
Trader you are and what it is you're
going to be looking at in the market so
for example if where's my chart here
right if I were to look at a f minute
chart can I look at stacked in balances
well of course I can doesn't mean I
can't look at certain things but I'll
probably focus on different aspects of
the order flow and Order flow is very
robust okay you got all the you got
Delta numbers to look at you got
obviously stacked imbalances you got
volumes in the bar if I was looking at a
longer time frame chart like a f minute
chart um I wouldn't expect to see a lot
of imbalances necessarily because you
have a five minutes to sort of come back
in fill in volumes like here right this
on the breakout right before that we had
nice stack buying imbalance coming in
here it's not here on a f minute chart
this one is still here and even here
right we had these stack selling
balances up in here it's not here
anymore just because the market had
plenty of time to fill it in doesn't
mean that there's no stacked imbalances
well there was on a shorter time frame
but on a longer time frame you're going
to focus on different aspects of the
order flow okay so that video you know
the longer time frame video orderflow
probably be another video in the future
um because I do get a lot of questions
you people ask me I am a swing Trader I
trade you know a f minute chart or a
15minute chart um how can I use
orderflow well you can even though I say
that orderflow you know is best used as
fresh as possible there are certain
things that are like these breadcrumbs
if you
will left in the market that you can see
on a footprint chart pretty clearly and
I'll make a video on that uh in the near
future all right so be sure to subscribe
to the channel so you'll get the
notification for when I do create that
video all right so I hope you guys enjoy
this video be sure to hit the Subscribe
button if you haven't already and again
you know thanks so much for watching and
I'll catch you guys on the next video
bye-bye